we're here in Chester Washington Golf
Course in Hawthorne / Inglewood adjacent
it's time for golf beep get the beef
with Rick that's a golf right there
definitely come out here play it's a
moccasin on the fairways of golfy kidney
straight takes a backseat to talking man
oh that's big Percy that man with the
terrible out that's red grant
these two lite-brite brothers are the
originators of golf tee cars T now did
you get the Sox first or the best mate
every night my crew play good I play
good he played goon and I play well
world can you go hang out with your
homeboys have a cigar get a couple
drinks do something halfway athletic get
mad at each other against a hill you
plan tomorrow just is how we do it I
won't get mad at him I've been managers
[Laughter]
not everything here is exactly PG a
sanction ball C figs on back checking
balls all day James gotta go fit okay
sorry oh I have to pee out all them bad
shot smoking uh weed inside of the
cigars play with retro when I'm not that
is that suit dogs fall I think that was
Luke dog ball
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah it's his home course to keep snoop
how defective Oh God
supposed to fight for I'll sit for here
watch your forehead a coma for let's
check out a new swing you got a stiff
ass takeaway change smacking all over
his face
you got some Greg Oden these look like
two-bit blunts Annie got a slice over
the top swinging you make Charles
Barkley look like Arnold Palmer man look
at chef Charles over here looking like
she's working on a railroad absolutely
impressive Phil Jackson Carmello era
it's ugly as hell and we wish we never
saw a couple of gaffer do one from a tow
for you
he's a man what else but I got Jordans
own I got yours Oh have you guys ever
encountered any haters any racist golf
is a game of equality right yeah you
feel me and because of equal you know
everybody treats each other equality but
they didn't let us in the golf course
sounds real yeah we was carrying bags
now we plant Thank You sacks might fall
it up you know what I'm very
professional and normally on the golf
course okay okay
[Applause]
so fight the winner of the British Open
receives the Claret Jug golf each has
his own rewards this war goes to the
ugliest golfer out hit you okay and not
only will his clothes be ugly but he and
his game is ugly
mrs. Danny Green for those who didn't
make the leaderboard well they always
have the next offbeat to look forward to
so it's all good thank you
my games will be in second I don't mean
a crappy brother yeah like they said it
[Music]